[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have another episode on
quantum computing
I'm really excited we have dr. Alexey
Marcin Cove joining us thank you for
coming up yeah thanks for inviting me
really appreciate it and we have a lot
to talk about this is a very important
field very grateful that we have you on
the show we had will Zang on the show a
couple weeks back and we're just
starting to scratch the surface on this
really important topic and actually you
were at Righetti for two years prior to
allow black Simo and so black Simone is
now two years for you found England yeah
so we incorporated in February 2017 yes
there was a company approaching two
years and so you did PhD in physics at
Leiden University in the Netherlands and
then you assume you were assistant
professor at Georgia Institute of
Technology that's right
for nine years that's a long time oh
yeah so before that I always all she
actually opposed look at UC Berkeley so
that's how I I came in to us and 97
Berkeley was the first place that fell
in what with that of course how you
cannot and yeah I liked your origin of
of like interest or excitement in the
universe because you said there's scales
and you you know humans are in the
middle and then there's the cosmos and
then the atoms and then you wanted to
play and test and and you that's why you
chose the small scale that's right yeah
so yeah so you can in physics you can
work with objects of any size and then I
really was fascinated by things very big
or very small and when I actually just
entered I and the most crazy issue
physics and technology and started
studying physics let's say
professionally this is when things like
skin
and atomic force microscopes were
invented and it became clear that you
can actually tinker with things like the
individual atoms and then I realized
that I really liked tinkering with
thanks and things very big like galaxies
and space are very fascinating but you
cannot make an experiment you can not
touch them you can observe and record
and make conclusions and I love tries
like hands-on stuff so that that
determine my career of working with
small things and when things are small
atomic they are quantum automatically
it's quantum mechanics and that's how
you basically start learning quantum
mechanics with all its weirdness and
tricks and yeah so that's been like this
for the whole life and career and then
what about your sort of understanding of
physics they got you into wanting to
compute what yeah where did that come
from
oh it's it's an applied field and I've
always loved computation so whenever
when you do physics ultimately you make
an experiment but you have to back it up
with numerical modeling or of data or
you can run actually some kind of
supercomputer simulation that would you
then compare with your experiment that's
sort of you know a justification that
you need to do and when I started when I
started studying physics computers where
there were no personal computers so to
speak right so like Commodore zatara's
game computers where this is the level
so 2086 Intel processor were suppose I
was rolled out when I was already like
on the fourth year of college and this
is where I really started doing sort of
computational simulations along with
experiments right and then you realize
that computation problems can be very
hard to do it's even if you go from
personal computers to supercomputers
that are just some problems that because
systems that they try to describe have
very complex equations they interact
with each other the amount of memory of
processing power just blows
up and you cannot simulate some systems
right and to me then after spending a
few many years and doing physics and
doing quantum physics wheeler I learned
about fineman's approach to quantum
computing that you need to use quantum
objects to simulate quantum objects but
it's really only in like 2005 maybe like
around that time it became clear that
you can actually do this right so you
can't aim small quantum mechanical
objects or actually make ones that
behave like quantum mechanic objects but
not small all right so that you can use
that you can do computing with quantum
objects and that's that's that's the
path and that's that's I love the
combination of the two yeah
what is the Fineman approach so he has a
very famous speech where he said we need
it's it's clear that computers classical
computers cannot be used to simulate
quantum quantum systems we need quantum
systems to simulate quantum systems
right and that's in this in essence what
we're trying to do right even the best
the biggest classical supercomputers
can't simulate no no no no no so there
are people use supercomputers for
simulating quantum objects but they take
certain approximations okay just to be
able to have enough memory and
processing power to describe in digital
modeling a quantum object so the amount
of memory is gigantic so if you take a
molecule like aspirin oh yeah that we
have actually sort of a graphics yeah of
that so it was what gives people
headaches and so to speak in computation
and aspirin is of course in Dragon games
headache but aspirin as a small molecule
and most drugs are small molecules right
so it's a small molecule that interacts
with a large molecule in your body like
a protein or something else and
combines the very last slide yet yeah
very last night yeah yeah this one yeah
so that'sthat's a molecule it's pretty
simple but very effective as we know so
it has only 21 atoms carbon hydrogen
oxygen very basic ones and it has 94
electrons so each atom has more than one
electron of course so to do a true
simulation of this kind of molecule
using basic quantum mechanical equations
you need something like 10 to the 48
bits of memory and just to give you the
stone model one most model with small
molecule like that so taking into
account motion of all electrons how they
interact with each other and all that
this is the difficulty all right so
electrons are charged particles when one
moves others feel but they're also
moving so this fills that and the rest
so then so it's it's it's sort of
nonlinear interaction as we call that
requires a gigantic amount of memory to
describe that honestly yeah ok just give
you this number is about like 1% of the
atoms that constitute earth so it's
impossible to build such a computer
right so like you imagine 1% of Earth
atoms being bit of memory yeah
to model that simple thing yes so there
is so this is this is this is yeah so
this amount of memory can in principle
be encoded by just about 168 quantum
quantum bits so in the case where those
qubits all talk to each other a block
entangled with each other right and
that's the power that's the power of
quantum computing because again I'm
talking about like one percent of Earth
atoms to be bits of memory and how did
qubits is something that can be in
principle if you use superconducting
technology and that's what we do we can
fit this number of qubits on this on
this on this on this on this plate so
the way this is a silicon wafer this is
something that people use in
semiconductor industry to make classical
computers this is a small one now what
people at Intel worked with 12-inch
wafers this is a four inch what about
dancing
two meters so you can put hundred and
sixty cubits on this on this plate in
principle right and this is something
that has a gigantic computational power
when we learn how to tame it now now
what what what what on this wafer is you
know versus that one versus one percent
of all the atoms on earth you know it's
just this one little wafer right you
know how what BIA what is going on here
that's enabling right so you have qubits
so quantum bits and this are in this
case there will be superconducting
qubits so essentially these are sort of
microwave circuits right so and our
superconducting qubits have small
elements called jewels and junctions
that's our quantum mechanical objects in
the sense and they make those qubits to
work okay so a quantum bit is something
that can take not only one or zero value
it can be in intermediate states and
when you entangle those qubits together
this is where the power of organization
comes from so they work all work here
until they amplify each other so to
speak so they probe all the possible
solutions of the problem with classical
computers you essentially need to look
at all the possible solutions one by one
and then choose the one that's that's
optimal so quantum chips they look at
all the possible solutions at once and
find the optimal one and give you the
answer and that's what makes them super
powerful at in theory yeah yeah that
that variant itself is such a probably
the most relatable explanation that I've
heard of the difference between
classical and quantum computing so why
what is the architecture of what is the
difference in in bits for quantum bits
that enables it to see all of the
options and then pick the one that's
most optimal that's this entanglement
phenomenon
all right so how did these 160 q quantum
bits how do they entangle with each
other how do they know how to work
together well so we we use microwaves to
run them okay so we design a circuit
where those qubits have a way of seeing
each other through microwave lines and
then we use external microwave pulses to
run the qubits and run algorithms
essentially by sending the microwave
pulse and that's actually it's about 5
to 10 gigahertz that's typical frequency
of what people use them in cellphones
right so you see that you send a pulse a
chirp
that's like shaped in a certain way and
then you can basically put your qubit in
the state that we desire and tangle
several qubits and run them so quantum
algorithms on superconducting circuits
essentially it is a bunch of in a
microwave sentence certain order you
know that will run a certain algorithm
and then you'll have the answer in the
end the answer by the way in the end
will be a bunch of zeros and ones
because when you measure a quantum
object right so it will be either 0 1
yeah so it cannot measure the
intermediate state when you network
yeah yeah so once it measured that's it
there is a bunch of bits and then you
have to interpret what it good at the
end like 160 zeros and ones how it
relates to the original problem that you
posed so so the funding and this is huge
congratulations one and a half million
dollars your seed round it's a seed
round yeah yeah that was recently
announced what a month ago pretty much
last month yes we closed the video over
there yes but the announcement was and
it's ember mid-september
and so who were the was it who were the
funders can we talk yeah so yeah we can
uh so interestingly enough the the elite
investor is a venture fund based in New
York and San Francisco it's called ENIAC
anyway in any echoes course is also the
name of the first practical
classical computers really so when I
teach to them I said guys I am building
the ENIAC of quantum computers and yeah
it was it was a very easy pitch after
that no it was not of course we went
after all
details but that's that's that's this is
a fun that's specializes in digital and
computing technologies right and then
the yeah so we're happy to have them as
partners that's a tremendous support
that they give us already and I want to
know about this you know this about this
one year let's say of this next these
next steps for you but I want to also
tie that into what we were just talking
about with the maker wave pulse that
comes are you learning how to design the
microwave pulse are you learning how to
design the wafer are you learning how to
optimize the all of that all of those
processes for specific applications like
what's happening in that you okay in
related at all all right so it's all of
them then it's so coupled right so the
problem is that you see in truth in
truth that it's designing those multi
qubit processors still more art than
science so we understand single qubit
technology all right so we understand
how to make those superconducting
quantum bits from superconductor from
from like microwave films Josephson
junctions and whatnot so we understand
how we can control a single qubit how we
can measure its characteristics so we
can actually even design this qubit to
certain parameters to some extent
fabrication it lags a little bit behind
right so we can design dimensions and
other parameters but when you start
fabrications they it's some of those
elements are very small some of the in
quick question yes is there a reason why
they're one centimeter apart from each
other
so it's it's the size decide the qubit
itself sort of superconductors are not
too small so to get the the the all the
all the junctions some electrodes and
and answers guides for the waves and
some filters takes about a few square
millimeters okay but this thing works as
a quantum object it's large but because
it's superconducting and use some
quantum macroscopic you say
superconducting effect it works as an
artificial atoms
right and that's the beauty of
superconducting technology by the way is
that we can design characteristics of
those atoms we can tune while their
approaches to quantum computing that
utilize ions vacances some impurities
magnetic computer chess and second this
is where you are given certain objects
right they're all identical and then it
works a little bit different is what we
do we can here to the circuit to our
desires in terms how qubits themselves
what's their critics and how they
interact with each other so now chip
design is where do you rank that in
terms of the importance of what you're
doing and then just the importance of
quantum computing successes chip design
at the top I think that's that yeah yes
so yeah so well there are two things
let's let's me put it this way so there
is a chip design free chip design itself
right because you have to be really
careful about how you design your qubits
if if the design is off or you don't
take into account like parasitic effects
the whole thing just is not going to
work manufacturing is the other thing so
we are always making yourself yes yeah
so when we go and what's the material
that you use so we are standard
technology in the sense so silicon
wafers that you see here works only the
substrate because it's a super flat
super smooth surface right so it's it's
reliably we semiconductor industry did a
lot of work to get us perfectly flat
surfaces to work with and that's very
important yeah and then we deposit we we
do some photography we it's it's a it's
a process of basically making masks so
which we then deposit metals then we
make junctions and then yeah so this is
something that's still done in labs so
there are some initiatives of and some
people who are thinking about building
foundries that is at some point you can
you can just make a cheap design and you
can order it somewhere else so at this
moment this kind of service is not
available yet right so sorry gate you
have their own fab in many clean rooms
and in top universities you can you know
run this this correspondent processes
but suits to be said is that the purity
of material how you prepare that and
that's you using your process only your
own stuff no one else touches those
installations is very critical for
performance so magnetic impurities and
that's something that's frequently
people use doing the objects this is
gonna kill your cheap your formal and
this it has to be in a vacuum setting
further not to be any impurities while
at all when the process going but say so
you have you have this metal deposition
that's what what you do is that you
basically you know boil metal within the
electronic beam or something else and
then it evaporates and then you have you
cheap with a mask and then it just
catches some of that paper so assume
that you you have an impurity somewhere
sitting around someone else is left it
also will go to vapor and will be
deposited on your wave some others okay
so that's that's design manufacturing
and third is right so design
manufacturing and and then actually how
you show them okay how you protect
because yeah show them because we
deliver microwaves right five gigahertz
but I said that that are powerful five
gigahertz it's it's about the frequency
the floor
how is actually very small so we work
with individual microwave photons the
signal that is required to run each
qubit is very small right as a single
photon and that's why it's sensitive
yeah it's not a Cuban yes and it's
Cascades the other ones too
so so to speak yeah so they that's the
level of the signal but of course in the
surroundings there is always like noise
electromagnetic noise oh yeah and even
an even sort of what's called blackbody
so each object radiates
photons and then depending on the
temperature right so you get a peak of
this radiation sort of frequency and
then so there are always photons
radiated by the environment that the
particular frequency could be it works
so that's why actually we cool down to
almost zero temperature it's just to
remove that thermal noise partly normal
noise normal noise on top of just after
the metal becomes superconducting that's
one use of low temperature but also a
reduction of noise and then you also
have to shield it you have to put
different kind of screens because it's
not only thermal noise but you know
people talking on cell phones and a lot
of noise comes for environments so these
things that very well have to be build
very well protected the signal slides
have to be perfect you need to do a lot
of you know this error error handling
error management because of that so you
need to be sure that the photons that
which your qubits microwave pulses only
the control one because anything else
any noise destroys the state of the
qubit and then the whole calculation is
destroyed so if you have like hundred
six you could be but one is you know one
makes an error right yeah so you're done
your calculation is not good wow-wow
design manufacturing and shielding what
a package and then that's not even
talking about the quantum programming
that right listen oh yeah what about
what about that well uh because we're
this is a prior to show we were talking
about the the funk though you have to
make you have to make this for specific
application like we are talking about
simulations like quantum chemistry for
the drug companies so that's our
approach and this is where we're a
little bit different from incumbents and
what Google and IBM are doing so they
are producing basically making sort of
certain qubit arrangements on their way
first and the count is 519 now it's
about 50 that's the next of IBM's Google
promises 72 or Acadia now has 19 I
believe but those qubits are
manufactured on the wafer and they and
certain in certain arrangement right so
it's we call it Universal processes
because ultimately sort of what these
companies say is that here is a quantum
processor this is how a cube is
connected now you guys need to figure
out how to use this architecture for the
particular problem you're solving yeah
yeah so with what try doing is a bit
different we're saying guys here is the
tell us what the problem is and we'll
make a chip that will solve that
particular problem or class of problems
like quantum chemistry more efficiently
so we will arrange qubits in a way that
it will run that particular calculation
much more efficient than the universal
architecture at least this is this is we
this is how few model systems were
thinking about and this is some this is
the next step for the company's
demonstration of of this concept all
right so it's it's gonna use qubits in a
much more efficient way so when you have
it's in the equivalent of SX
application-specific integrated circuits
and it's now in everyday life because
your iPhone and you know contains mostly
application specific circuits even your
graphics card in computer you know is an
application today so why it works with a
particular type of data particular
process much faster so that to us is the
best way to achieve and demonstrate the
usefulness of a quantum computation for
real problems yeah okay because we
already have it in our phones and our
computers in terms of the application
specific integrated search yeah a so
yeah and so they only make sense to do
the same thing for all the different
quantum computing problems and
simulations that we want to run yeah it
doesn't even seem like it makes sense
why would why so Google and IBM or maybe
they're trying to take a they're trying
to take a one-size-fits-all versus a
make it for the specific case I wouldn't
speak for them but I think that
a lot of approaches we are now at the
stage of development of the field where
quantum of vision field we're really a
lot of approach needs to be tried
so we have evidence theoretical and some
experimental that the owl Pro which can
give advantage whether the market will
be such that Essex will win or like more
Universal computer will ultimately be
the winner time will show the universal
computers though everyone acknowledges
that you build them takes something like
about ten years plus and to us costs our
Welman so just to give you a number to
run one single qubit superconducting
qubit okay you need the fridge
refrigerator you need electronics and
even if you just calculate time and
materials it can be anything between
twenty and forty thousand dollars per
single qubit Wow it's giving you like
the cost of a machine it's not much less
if you use some other technology right
so tens of millions of dollars four
hundred qubit yeah a machine yeah okay
you want some how it work and to us
optimization of the processor because
the rest the fridge the rest it doesn't
matter it's the same cost ninety five
percent is there so the process
architecture and how it utilizes the
qubit count is the key thing to like
demonstration that that's outtake so
that's how we will approach in a way the
cell first computers were built any act
which we search already was exactly
hardwired to do certain problems right
and then blocks were assembled together
to reprogram now to do another problem
in a way I think we need as a quantum
computing industry to you could just go
through the same path
interestingly enough the the these are
even though these are applications
specific they also give just enough
openness to for you to run all of these
different operations on so is that
something runs something runs your
display something runs
something else right but they work
together so they work like as logical
modules that perform a lot of functions
but when you program those things of
course at the entity at the level of
program and at some point the fact that
it's an application specific
architectural chip it's taken into
account but programmers of apps do not
see that anymore because this is the
this has been developed already into the
environment like high-level language
where II don't need to think about that
so we still need to think about that we
still need to think about how to run
qubits at an elementary level so it used
to be called the assembler language you
know you really need to understand you
know how pulse propagates down to the
chip how it's runs on the chip or the
does etcetera etcetera as the industry
will grow at some point too when we will
have probably some universal design
tools and software who are quantum chips
but at the moment we really are just you
know arranging it by hand scene you know
how it works whether it's coherent
whether it will give us answer it will
stay you know coherent and then if you
move something the rest can follows and
that's that's why it's still not I've
really really enjoyed how your you know
your hypothesis about the futures that
we still don't know what is gonna win a
universal one or application specific
one but I'm I'm liking how you're
describing that specific one and I and I
like this example I think explaining
this example a little bit more would be
really helpful that the it's it's really
expensive to understand quantum
chemistry and so pharmaceutical
companies are constantly trying to
understand how chemicals react and run
simulations for that so in this case you
can do things like better understand
personalized medicine and just save
billions of dollars in these so why
don't you explain this to us a bit yes
so yes so when you talk about a drug at
the elementary level so what happens is
there's a small molecule aspirin or
other molecule sales but the same size
it's like tens of atoms so ultimately
they need to interact with something in
your body that causes the disease
frequently it's a protein
you know and then they need to
chemically bind to each other right so
and this is a quantum mechanical
reaction so binding is a quantum
mechanically so when molecules small one
binds to a large one a quantum
mechanical process happens okay and
that's where we can do the simulation so
why is that first of all just in numbers
so pharmaceutical industry is 75 billion
dollars a year on R&D research and
development and drug development only so
typically to get one fda-approved drug
so you require 10,000 of those candidate
molecules and about 10 years of time out
of which should the first like 2 or 3 I
spend on pre selecting these molecules
before they go to preclinical and
clinical trials ok so 10,000 becomes one
of the approved drug so it's typically
about again 10 years and but depends how
we calculate but what people say it's
about 2.5 billion dollars some some some
drugs can do like cheaper some can be
super expensive but that's the average
if you just cut you know out of those
10,000 molecules reduce at least through
simulations some number of molecules
that are likely to fail during this
expensive trial
you're saving billions of dollars okay
so ultimately why people don't do this
well people do they try but to simulate
that interaction is difficult on
classical computers as we discussed yes
you know so 21 atoms that's it that's
what you can get so the precision is not
there it's very expensive it's very
costly
so this is where like quantum computing
can be super helpful in the industry
like that but of course there are
audiences like petrol energy we're
similar like chemical reactions so
molecular interactions take place and
then this approach in principle is the
same as for drug design or for when you
are the industrial users and then it's
quantum chemistry it's to speak like yes
what other applications are you
going to be taking on clients to the
quantum chemistry is the is something
that's the easiest thing to do and the
reason is this so as I mentioned you
have a quantum mechanical reaction on
one side right so these are your
molecules and you have a quantum
mechanical processor on the other side
right so you need somehow to simulate
like fineman's original ideas simulate
one quantum system with you with the
help of the other one so we call it
mapping all right so this this kind of
problem is quantum on one side and are
the easiest to map you on on like to
make the algorithm that will simulate
this behavior with this chip ok so
that's that's that's how you start but
ultimately this kind of you can you can
you can work with classical problems as
well so you need to learn how to take a
classical problem and typically a lot of
the problems are optimization problems
right so they involve some cost function
so-called cost functions that you need
to minimize to get an answer right so
it's important to understand how to map
those classical problems on to quantum
chips right and whether this quantum
mechanical system really simulates well
the behavior of your classical in a way
though in drug design or audiences
that's what we do but our cost function
is energy because ultimately chemical
binding is finding the NEEMO of the
energy when those molecules basically
bind together and that will be the
configuration so the approach is gonna
work the way we approach the problem is
going to work for optimizing classical
cost functions it's just that it's the
easiest way to do for us now quantum to
quantum and then people but people start
thinking about already a lot of
practical problems in the optimization
machine during an AI that can utilize
quantum algorithms so do you write the
quantum algorithm to yourself and no so
this is where
theorists and very small people are
required to do that so we collaborate
with theoretical groups that develop
quantum algorithms that we can you know
then run on our processors so we are
focused on hardware development and
particularly particularly on chip
development there is a lot still to do
and this is the key if you don't have a
chip you don't have a computer right so
that's that's that's what we focused on
as a company and collaborate with
scientists are the groups and other
startups to build full stack machines
and actually you know how they each side
yeah as well so then they're quantum
algorithms will enable you to run it on
your chip which can then make the
simulations happen of the quantum
chemistry yeah so yeah so the simulation
problem is posed then they write sort of
it in the quantum mechanical language
yeah yeah some some calculations are
done how to solve that constant chemical
problems on the chip right that in
quantum mechanical language oh well so
it's some problems are easier to write I
mean
quantum mechanics in the ways is a
beautifully simple theory because
equations are so it so simple to write
it's just a few few terms and that's it
it's very difficult to solve so once you
you can formulate a quantum mechanical
problem in a very inefficient way and
then but you can also work theoretically
so that it's kind of become simpler to
solve and this is at that point where we
can feel it so so we need some work some
optimization some simplification of a
very generic set containing the problems
to still run out on quantum chips so
that's the work that people who are
theoretical physicists do right so these
are the specialists I'm an
experimentalist liked to tinker with
things understand try to understand what
these smart people really do but yeah
I'm focused on
you know build anything go get things
well okay what does it look like once
blech Simone gets rolling what does it
look like for what you actually you
taught me the name is what it in land
it's it's now it's Greek it's Greek
entanglement means entanglement
in green Greek black Simone that's so
cool and then okay so what happens once
black smoke gets more momentum like with
with designing manufacturing chips
running simulations once we get momentum
does the chip gets sold to the Pfizer do
you design chip specifically for Pfizer
there's Pfizer
sends you simulations and you have an
army of chips that you've designed for
them so at this moment so there is the
vision is as follows
so industries and companies that can
afford quantum computing right now to be
exclusive for them let me put this way
so our big corporations okay so our
approach is that we first talk to
clients in those corporations and see
the particular pain points when they
utilize high-performance computing some
numerical methods and see whether they
we can help by building an accelerator
because again this computer our chip
will not replace a supercomputer it will
work in conjunction with them but it can
really solve some things cheaper faster
more precise like the energy of
interaction that no classical computer
can solve yeah okay
so we will work with particular clients
first and then the hope is that and
again this this comes from some
experience basically I I've done some
research back at Georgia Tech where as I
mentioned we did experiment and then we
had a supercomputer simulation that
run simulated the behavior of that
system so the hope is that the chips
that would build will be universal
enough there were still application
specific meaning this is a quantum
chemistry or drug design chip but it
should not be thought as this chip is
like it's to build for this molecule and
we for the for the other molecule we
need to build another chip it's not like
that yeah right so we will provide a
platform where we can basically build an
accelerator for a class of problem
particular class of problems for
particularly industry yes that will then
utilize that underneath that builds a
library that you yeah so a logical
course of you way also the architecture
how you build say for the you can think
about company like synopsis right that's
that's your typical company that
provides solutions like in terms of
logical course and how to build systems
from chips application-specific
processors for different ministries so
we believe that quantum region industry
will develop like that we are in the
early stages of where we're still kind
of trying to tame the this power right
but we can start building practical
systems even with the current level of
technology that's who how BIG's the
company how many people are you hire you
know we're hiring so we have six people
right now so we'll hope to grow to 10
people by the end of this year these
PhDs and physics most uhm actually
engineering primarily so we are we are
affiliates electrical mechanical making
yeah so in computer science so we were
likely to get into an accelerator called
cycling Road this is this is an
accelerate based at the Lawrence
Berkeley Lab and there are other people
there who are physicists and engineers
who are interested in working on those
problems as well and they collaborate
with us and that's it's a good part of
being there so you can really sort of
leverage the expertise that the
Department of Energy
building those labs and facilities and
mechanical shoppers there is no any
other in the world I think that that can
be compared to what they have up there
the clean rooms has already been built
there are some processes that already
been set up that are suitable for us to
utilize and building quantum chips so
overall that gave us a tremendous boost
in terms of my company development so we
don't need to build many things from
from the grounds we just can leverage
whatever is out there yeah okay and now
what do you think is the most
interesting part of what is going on in
the quantum computing explosion that
we're experiencing I think that's that
the realization that applications are
nearer then people thought even a few
months ago yeah it's something that
settles in many people's mind and people
start looking at quantum computing as
something that they need to start using
and thinking about something that's near
term there is even in terminal called
misc no is the intermediate state
quantum process that describes the level
of the development of quantum technology
and this term is now on everyone's mind
and people understand that we can now
build integrated circuits we can build
circuits with tens and hundreds scan of
qubits in the nearest future let's take
a look at how we can utilize that power
at the current level to do practical
problems and this is what a lot of
conferences now are being arranged
around so it was one in Canada two weeks
ago the one big one down here in Palo
Alto in December European and worldwide
so that's that's I think we're very
excited very exciting era we are now in
this mystical field
what's acronym again misc misc noisy
intermediate scale quantum intermediate
scale refers to tens and hundreds cubits
because Universal ones will require like
Heights and thousands of millions of
cubits oh wow so nice get something
again that's something that will will be
on on in the single refrigerator on a
single wafer like that and take it about
the size of this room or so that's
that's the airway in and that's what a
lot of people start working on they
realizing that that's that's very close
and did you just say that even a hundred
cubit wafer has to be in a fridge space
as big as this room yeah I all the
fridge is the same for one qubit or and
or hundred cubic yeah yeah
so you you require a little bit of
mechanical equipment to run it then you
require like control electronics but
let's also not forget that four so four
accelerators like we built any computer
you still need like a lot of servers
like classical servers to run you need
to control your machines you need to
control your microwave electronics in to
interpret data and do that so that's why
I'm saying computer equipment racks plus
fridges but it's the feeling is that
it's there so it's it's very exciting to
to be to live in this time so this is
something you can already like vision or
I can envision that's something that's
within the range so they were very
excited and black somewhere to be you
know able to work on that so most of us
for the whole life you know dreamt about
something like that it's difficult
problem buts you know we feel that only
difficult problems are words do you is
there something else I want to ask you a
couple questions that we typically ask
on the show is there something else
related to black Simo related to the
near term quantum computing that we
definitely need to mention before about
the company itself or even about
near-term quantum computing in general
yeah what your
doing in the spaces there's something
else that you think's really pressing
that we should speak on something secret
of course
so again I think that's the quantum
computers become in an industry so there
are companies that now work on different
pieces that are useful for quantum
region like refrigerators or special
electronics or special methods to work
with errors in software for one special
amplifiers so it's really becoming an
industry right people start thinking
about that and that's what what makes me
think that we are accelerating as the
industry and applications will be here
and practical news here much earlier
than most people kind of project you
sometimes can hear five ten years plus
never I think we were more optimistic
about that yeah so that's that's I think
that's that's that's my impression
I like your breakdown that there are so
many individual components to the
quantum computing explosion the industry
that's going on so people can focus on
just the three strengths of chip design
right so yeah I think again the core is
the chip we're still always still
struggling with I'm still struck here I
understand the microwave pulse and how
that and it helps in tango and how the I
don't even I still don't how the
information goes the information is in
the microwave pulse and then it cascades
into the information is the in in qubits
in this intermediate states microwave
pulses control them control control the
algorithm the flow of the calculation
right but the power is quantum mechanics
you know how does it affect that's the
question come in into the this this is
this is this is that's it right so yeah
so it's it's the question comes as you
prepare thrust those qubits and in
certain states this is how you start
kind of calculation but the input comes
in the process yeah so the input comes
in via microwave Paul
then the cubits entangle into and and
then you still control them with
microwave policy so you do the
calculation of the bosses yeah when you
measure you get one output you're when
you measure that's a measure measurement
process yes you recall it collapse
collapse yes it collapses from this yeah
into zero one so that's there and that's
that's the power and the difficulty we
cannot correct errors in the way because
once we measure that's it so you measure
you collapse the Oh Calculon I want to
run a simulation the size of Earth and I
just want to just because I want to see
what happens when we evolved when humans
evolved with different variables like
what would have happened if we were
closer or farther from the star the
planet was bigger or smaller or
evolution maybe the asteroid didn't hit
and hit the dinosaurs how much longer
would have they been here I love
questions like this and so I like to I
want to run those simulations I think
that's again so we are talking about the
problems that are very demanding in
terms of the scale of the calculations
it is that's why we need write something
like that but look I mean it's all
important it's important to understand
how you posed the question and if this
algorithm thing right so in digital
computers you know if you posed the
question not the right way you will get
an answer but is this answer worth it
yeah you get a bunch of numbers you need
to interpret them right so but so but
problems like that require large-scale
calculations like lots of data to be
processed or the model is so complex
that you memory requirement explodes
when you do the calculation it's
something that this these quantum
machines can handle as no other digital
platform can yes right so we need to
just pose the private question law write
an algorithm all right
and then this calculation will
definitely be possible yeah that's great
that you care about how the question is
proposed because that's what yeah that's
what we do so much on the shows we
figure out how to propose the question
and then hear how the guest answers it
the industry is exploding I want to ask
you a couple questions on the way out
that we ask our guests I like see what
do you think about this do you think we
are alone in the cosmos I hope not I
hope not I subscribe to theories that
sort of tell that intelligence is
possible elsewhere the question is
whether it's the same as ours and to me
and this is I love I love nice Laflamme
III know if you notice there's this
sci-fi writer he was a physicist by
education the question is that even
though we are not alone whether we're
capable of communicating with each other
we cannot communicate between like two
people like a relationship between two
humans is a difficult part we look at
the same thing but I doubt that we see
the same thing by the way you and I have
a very different perception of that
object totally so to me it's it's really
the question is whether we'll be able to
communicate this is very fascinating
I've been always fascinated by that
scene if there is any any other
civilizations whether we send like
satellites or sensing like microwave
pulses to space but maybe they're
thinking in a different like in
neutrinos some proposed or something
like wow yeah you know so that that's
something that still fascinates me sort
of on the level that's not like building
practical things and this is still my
connection to the big cosmos sex yeah
thanks yeah I keep following what's
going on in astronomy and cosmology
as it's very fascinating I think we're
not alone though yeah would telepathy be
the best form of communication I well I
think that we need to know how are the
other aliens what I would call brains
work whatever they have for brains to me
this will be a method but something like
more elementary needs to be you know
established first but ultimately
telepathy is doing in your brain
completely in sync with something else
as I said let's try to like to human
size to do that between ourselves then
think about that as a man that runs so
many simulations on behalf of other
people do you think that this is a
simulation Oh like us yes some days feel
like that Oh sometimes I look what you
know so in a way in a way so I prepare a
quantum chip I send their pulses this
thing evolves I subscribe to the theory
that Big Bang started everything and
then it evolves it's in in a way it's a
simulation yeah whether it's a single
one ever or there are billions of
parallel universes where you know we
started at the same point and they
evolved in in a different way so I would
say yes so ultimately you know we are
I'm a physicist I I do believe in laws
of physics right so we may not
understand some but definitely the
evolution of like the universe as a
whole is run by physical laws so in a
way it's a simulation I just hope that
you know we can change things a little
bit but whether it's a part of
simulation or we there is a free will
I I subscribe to the theory at least I
hope that we have free will and we have
a way of changing things so and then
last question is what do you believes
the most beautiful thing in the world
you know honestly and this is a little
this little bit in sync with what I just
said I think that self-awareness is
something that is a gift is a curse
sometimes but it's a gift
right because intelligence exists in
different forums there is very primitive
like organisms that you can say are
intelligent but the fact that were
self-aware and then control you know
this is this is something that I think
is the most beautiful in this is what's
worth what makes me believe that we can
do thanks and just not flow with
something right so that that's that we
can drive we can make conscious
decisions we can reflect back you know
and if some decisions are on we can
correct them but that's to me I guess it
very is a very beautiful thing blessed
that we were given the consciousness by
evolution and here we are today and and
if we can reflect better and move
forward more effectively as a
civilization then I think we can make it
longer than we ever thought before I I
think so I think communication is a big
is a very big thing just on the human
level even so I was always fascinated by
Social Sciences as well and actually one
of the things that I was kind of playing
with a little bit before switching full
time to quantum computing is actually
whether you can do simulations of social
processes and thought process I think so
I think and there there are books
written about that
there are models but this is don't you
run those all the time when you walk
down the street you choose to smile you
choose to frown there's a simulation oh
you see how the other person reacts you
hold the door open you choose the right
you walk Yeah right but globally this
system is so complex and whether we can
sort of improve something I mean it's
the point of simulation is not sometimes
understand but to need some proof right
yeah we're working on this because this
is a quality different level of how we
can do things in so many domains that we
cannot even predict them we're so social
to me will be very important as well so
just how to run like society run in the
way that understand but why why there is
hunger where everything says that we
have abundance of resources yeah it's
something maybe very small thing which
we're missing because the same system is
so complex maybe these things will
happen that yeah yeah so this is a very
complex highly interacting system maybe
we can do some social modeling in
quantum systems that can solve not only
practical problems like drug but like
problems on their own on a larger scale
agreed yes I'm so excited for the near
term quantum computing future
thank you something right thanks for
inviting me was pleasure thank you so
much for coming on and for building this
future we desperately need you and other
people to pool resources and get
involved in this we know that you know
China took on their ten billion dollar
quantum computing initiative and the US
government needs to get behind this
launcher for nurse private entities need
to get behind this more funding behind
it this is fascinating stuff to the chip
design and manufacturing and and
actually understanding how qubits work
and what that means for computing it's
where I'm know nothing about I'm
discussing the surface and I hope as
civilization weekend
we can really dig deep and figure it out
it's up to you guys as well it's up to
all of you definitely get involved in
the space if you find if you find it
interesting give us a comment below let
us know what your thoughts that we're on
the episode we'd love to hear from you
also do check out blocks mo comm the
links on the bio go check them out Ron
thank you for producing and directing
much love to you
thanks everybody for tuning in also
remember that we need your help with
with prospering here at simulation so do
join us we have our patreon as well in
the bottom support us help us grow much
love everyone
[Applause]
you